whatever you think about trump we have
seen that guy up close and personal
he tweets all the time there are
misspellings he gets right in your face
he gets right in the reporter's face
he speaks off the cuff probably the most
transparent president certainly of my
lifetime
and probably in recent history as well
that closeness is not going to occur if
joe biden is the president
you're going to see a distance from him
he's going to repeat the same platitudes
that we've heard from empty suit
politicians for a long time
he's going to contradict himself it
won't matter he will not be the one
calling the shots or running the show he
will be empowering the
liberal state the same cast of
characters that have been around forever
we talked about yesterday how he's named
john kerry his
climate czar a new position i guess john
kerry has been around since the 70s he's
just he's
comes in and out he's a senator he's a
secretary of state doesn't matter how
much he fails he just
remains there a lot of obama alumni
believe that if joe biden is named
president
they will go back to the white house
that is what
you're going to see if if he makes it
there the argument for this by the way
it's not i'm not reading the tea leaves
or something
the left is telling us this themselves
andrea mitchell on nbc news
came out and said of joe biden's cabinet
picks that the best thing about the
cabinet picks
is that they're not political they
are now being told that it is not going
to be political and joe biden is saying
these are people this is a team who is
going to tell me this team will tell me
what i need to know what not what i want
to know that
is a big change that's a big change
they're going to push
back on me first of all
andrew mitchell's contrasting this to
the trump white house where there were
vying factions from the very beginning
talk about pushback
in the biden white house what are they
even pushing back on joe biden doesn't
believe anything
of course they'll just tell them they
won't tell him what he wants to hear
they'll tell him what they want to hear
and he'll just acquiesce because he's an
empty suit
but beyond that i i almost can't believe
she said it with a straight face
until i remember the left's ideology but
she actually said
that the political appointees who are
going to be running the
executive agencies of our government are
not
political what does that mean
how can you be a cabinet secretary and
not political
well the reason that andrea mitchell can
say that
is because for the left they believe
that their politics are not really
is not really politics they believe that
their politics is scientific
and the left has said this for 150 years
at least
that they've discovered the science of
history and the science of politics
and they have their expertise and so
they're not having the push and pull
typical political debates that we've had
in republics going back to ancient
greece
no they have discovered the science of
politics and so if you disagree with
them you've got to be profoundly stupid
or evil or both
in any case it's not legitimate to
disagree
stop making this so political it's this
we've mentioned this on the show before
in this world of leftist political
science
everything becomes political except for
politics which is depoliticized
and handed to experts so i bet she
really does believe this
that the cabinet won't be political
it'll just be scientific it'll just be
common sense
and you better not disagree with it
that's pretty scary because it's so
tone deaf you know one one thing that
i've noticed in the culture and you see
this borne out by various
studies that show that conservatives are
much more willing to hear out liberals
than liberals are willing to hear about
conservatives and
the bombed out cities around this
country from the blm riots probably show
you that
it's that we understand basically what
the left's point is
maybe we we need to be filled in on the
details but we broadly understand what
they believe
they have no idea what we believe they
have no idea that we reject
the the fundamental premises of their
worldview
and every time they do kind of gather
that idea
they try to shut us up and ostracize us
and call us nazis and all that sort of
thing
we're going to get a whole lot more of
that if joe biden becomes president
on msnbc the anchors couldn't
contain their excitement they described
the cabinet as the avengers
to talk about joe biden's empathy and
humanity to talk about diplomacy being
back
it is all an implicit rebuke
of donald trump's foreign policy
stewardship over the last four years
that's right and then just saying that
they're going to do their jobs
and be good stewards of america's role
in
this world and i'm focused on american
diplomacy that in and of itself
um being a rebuke of president trump is
uh
underscores what we've all been living
through in the last four years this is
a president who wanted to be more
isolationist who wanted to pull back
uh hold on hold on a second i just need
to before i get into the stupid points
they're trying to make about biden
i need to point out donald trump has had
the most successful
foreign policy of any president since
the end of the cold war
it's not even close he's an isolationist
he's pulling back he's abandoning our
allies
we have had greater peace under donald
trump than under any president
in my lifetime he is pulling away
uh no he's not he's actually solving the
middle east peace crisis
clinton couldn't do it bush couldn't do
it obama couldn't do it
but trump somehow is getting major peace
deals signed with israel and all of
these different arab neighbors
is it just a fluke no he took a
different approach
an approach that was explicitly rejected
by former secretary of state
future climate charge john kerry who
said it could never work trump tried it
it did work
peace deals in serbia new trade deals
with china new trade deals with mexico
new trade deals with canada
getting the nato allies to start paying
for nato
this had been official u.s policy for
years no president figured out how to do
it trump did
the idea that trump is some isolationist
who bungled foreign policy is insane
he did better at foreign policy and
hopefully he continues to do better at
foreign policy
than any president in the last quarter
century
but then they go on to make their point
about the cabinet and this
is what is so preposterous
they believe that the cabinet this lame
drawling drooling old desiccated cabinet
are superheroes what we saw today i was
sitting in that room in wilmington um i
was thinking about the fact that joe
biden in some ways
first supporters is fulfilling the
promises that he made on the campaign
charlie said he wanted to have a cabinet
that looked like america and there were
people there on that stage of course
talking about all of their different
faculties and their experience but they
were also talking about their families
who survived the holocaust who survived
coming from cuba and flink
communists who talked about um having
gumbo
diplomacy cooking food cooking southern
food as the united nations ambassador
thing um all of those things are what
america is about it's a melting pot the
other thing i'll just say is i was
talking to a democrat
who just said this also felt like the
avengers it felt like we're being
rescued from this
this craziness that we've all lived
through from the last four years and now
here are the superheroes to come and
save us all here are the superheroes and
what are their qualifications what are
their super powers
can they fly no can they think
not really but they can look a certain
way
yes they can have different colors of
skin
and this is an amazing superpower
different sexual appendages
i know that you know all those things
were true under trump too but
you know it's super duper under joe
biden
this is identity politics on steroids
right this is what this woman says
we need a cabinet that looks like
america well what do you mean by looks
like america you mean
do you mean in the sense that the
cabinet thinks like americans think
that the cabinet has the same love of
country that
americans generally have that they have
the same interests the same hobbies the
same cares and concerns no
what she means is they've got to be
diverse meaning
you know different colors and sex and
everything and when they say look like
america by the way what they're really
saying is
actually look more diverse than america
you have to have
one of every single type of person with
certain physical traits
there's something beyond stupid here
obviously it's very stupid and shallow
and pretty offensive but there's
something beyond that that's that's even
it's even more depressing which is that
the focus on identity politics here the
color and sex of these cabinet picks
shows you that the individual members
don't matter at all
it doesn't matter if any of these people
are talented
and from the pics that we've heard of so
far they're not talented
they're not particularly intelligent
they're not particularly accomplished
none of these guys most especially john
kerry
they're just there to fill a space
to be an empty suit because
they are the conduit for the liberal
technocracy to rule
that's the i mean that's the the really
revealing aspect of the identity
politics
is no one is focusing on whether these
people are competent to do their jobs
and they're not actually but it doesn't
matter because they're not even doing
the jobs
we have had in this country for decades
now
a bureaucracy that operates largely
without democratic oversight
that just makes all our policy for us
the presidents may change but the
foreign policy is supposed to
stay the same the administrations may
come and go
but the giant bureaucracy that employs
millions of people will keep
will keep operating and trump disrupted
that in a limited way he wasn't able to
totally upend the deep state or the
bureaucracy but he made
changes here and there changed policy a
little bit and then the
establishment fought back they think
that they vanquished him we still don't
know for sure
and now they want to govern again
without any of that democratic oversight
and so all of these
these uh cabinet picks and
joe biden himself there will be little
ornaments on the christmas tree little
shiny things to look at
but the substance of the government will
be that
bureaucracy if you enjoyed that video
and i
would hope that you did please be sure
to hit the subscribe button
so that all of the befuddled radicals
wading through the wasteland of youtube
knows where they can get the truth
thanks